each year Microsoft Research hosts
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely available
introduce Andy bagel who is visiting us
from Berkeley as some of you may know
there's a new research effort within
Microsoft Research looking at basically
the intersection of HCI style research
and software engineering so we're
interested in studying programmers as
users and Andy fits right into that mold
today he's going to talk to us about
what it might be like to enter programs
via voice instead of keyboard and he
assures me that that is alfin a
contentious topic and welcomes you to
interrupt for questions and feedback
throughout the talk but we won't hassle
on too much anyway thanks Andy
this year I'll play the summer and its
programming by voice and
okay oh wow even I can't hear that all
right well you know I can introduce
myself again I'm Andy bagel for all the
people watching from home and I work an
interactive software development so let
me motivate what I'm talking about today
which is per game by voice so
conventionally most programmers use
keyboard they program for long hours and
and are thus at risk for getting
repetitive strain injuries or carpal
tunnel problems with their hands and if
you think about it if you're a
programmer and you're keyboarding is
your lifestyle and you get RSI you're
kind of out of a job so it might be time
to look for something new except what we
are doing is trying to find an
alternative so we said it we asked the
question can you use speech as an
alternative for typing in the
programming task and what's interesting
about that is that it takes speech which
is a very inherently ambiguous domain
which is spoken English and combines it
with something that's completely
unambiguous programming languages in
fact mathematically precise they have to
be exact and programmers understand that
so what we found is that this is also a
really interesting area to study
ambiguity mediation something that
Jennifer magnet off at Georgia Tech work
done and so what the general goal is is
with all sort of human scent of research
you first look at your users you look at
your programmers and you say well if you
could speak code what would you say and
find out how they would verbalize the
code what kinds of things they need to
do in order to read the code out loud
and then use this to help develop some
input form that the computer can
understand then what we do is we build a
development environment that works with
this new input form and it turns out
that it requires quite a bit of program
analysis in order to understand it and
I'll explain why and finally what we do
is we then test it with the developers
to make sure that our design is
interesting it could work and try to
iterate and figure out some better ways
to do things that once we figure out
whether it works or not so there are
four challenges in this research the
first programming languages are not
designed to be spoken programming is a
activity it's on the written media and
it's never really been spoken before so
taking this to a verbal medium is sort
of a challenge speech is ambiguous
programming languages or not so this
means that you're going to have to
somehow figure out what the user what
the human intended to program onto the
computer when you are transcribing the
code thirdly speech tools that come with
commercial speech recognition from those
vendors is actually really poorly suited
for code and I'll explain why sort of
towards the end of the talk and finally
programmers obviously aren't used to
verbal software development because well
they've never really had a chance to do
before so this is something that will
have to work this is sort of a training
issue if you will now in the topic I'm
just going to go through a bunch of
things I'm going to start now just sort
of illustrated when I really mean by
programming by voice so let's say we've
got a for loop on the screen and I'm
trying to count from 0 to 9 and I want
to do it by voice so let's take what you
have to do if you are using the current
state of the art which is called voice
code which comes from alain de la in
National Research Council in Canada so
here we've got a person saying for loop
which introduces a code snippet
something very familiar to you guys then
we say after left for em to move the
cursor over to the first hole in the
template then we say declare India of
type integer so in most voice
recognition tools you use the military
alphabet to spell words especially a
single syllable words like I to make
sure that you get them right you in this
language you say the type of the
variable after you say the name of the
variable and then we say assigned 0 not
equal 0 because in this language you
have to say a sign so there's sort of a
custom vocabulary that you have to learn
and then say after semi to move the
cursor over to the next template then we
say recall one now what's interesting
about this if you look in the left
there's something called the cash pad
because it's difficult to say identifies
in most cases identifiers are a lot
longer series of words every time you
say an identifier it gets dumped into
this cash pad and then you can reference
it by number instead of by name and
number recognition and voice
direct answers is fantastic as opposed
to arbitrary words or sequences of words
so we say recall one to grab the eye out
of the cash pad and then we say less
than 10 and then after something to move
to the next piece of the code template
and then recall one again to get the eye
and then increment not plus plus because
again in this language you say increment
and then say after left brace to move
into the body of the for loop now at
this point we run into one more problem
which is that after the template is
filled in it's gone so forever after our
editing is now based on text move
forward five characters with back ten
characters there's no like concept of
these chunks anymore so in the space of
programming by voice there's been a
bunch of work for people trying to
develop these systems and I've put them
on two different axes so let's take the
left axis this is basically how many
tasks the in software development how
many fascinating sort of software
programming does the tool support now
most tools actually only support
authoring you can write the code but
once you get it into your editor you're
pretty much then on your own editing
text some tools very few actually
support multiple tasks like navigation
and editing none of these tools support
tasks outside of the scope of what you
do with your editor now on the bottom
axis we have whether the tools computer
centric or human centric and computer
centric means that the human adapts to
the way the computer wants you to speak
so like something like graffiti on a
Palm Pilot you need to learn how to use
graffiti in order for the speech right
in order for the handwriting recognition
to work by contrast we've got
human-centric which is i means where you
where the computer is trying to figure
out what you want to say and obviously
there's a continuum here I kind of vote
for solutions on the side of human
centric solutions now we've got all
those related work actually two of them
I can take away because they never
actually were implemented there were
just designs and actually of course
where I want to be is at the top right
where you always want to be in a graph a
human centric solution that solves
multiple tasks navigation and editing as
well as code authoring
now what we did to start is we did the
study to find out how 10 Java
programmers 10 expert programmers would
speak code if they were handed the page
of code out loud and told specifically
you are driving a person at the keyboard
a sophomore in computer science who's
taken Java but does not know anything
about what you're trying to code and
read this code out loud as if you were
doing that and I tape recorded it and
then analyzed the results so this is
actually being published in the VL HTC
in September so the first thing we found
out which was very you know one of those
thank goodness moments pretty much
everybody speaks the same way which is
you know not was not a given when I
first started this research because
there's absolutely nothing in the
literature that says everybody knows how
to say code out lab so what do people
say well here's our for loop what people
said was for int I equals 0 I less than
10 I plus plus they said the natural
language words that you see on the
screen they did not say the parenthesis
they did not say the semicolons they
they didn't say the braces they didn't
say they said plus plus so they kind of
separated those two tokens that that
token over here they did not say a few
other things which I'll get to which is
a problem but for the most part you guys
listening to for ins i equals 0 i less
than 10 a-plus-plus you all figure that
that was a for loop I wouldn't even have
had to show that on the screen but
there's actually a problem let's say we
want to actually have a computer
understand this but yes i get 0 rather
than i equals 0
I sometimes say it I didn't see any of
the 10 set so very nobody said something
called in this case ya know he's a
tinkling for i going from 0 tonight one
person said for i from 1 to 10 actually
and he was an expert program what's just
good it's very close so it was yes
that's good so there were some weird
things that people said that i want to
go over so how would you say the first
construct on the screen there guess who
is anyone else
who has to eat who hasn't everyone said
the word food before the word it that's
exactly what most programmer said except
they had this problem because they're
reading the code so they said Kass
something to integer that's something
his food because they needed to find
they needed to say something for the
sentence structure but they didn't
actually see the word food yet because
they were reading the word games so
there was a little awkwardness if you
with the structure of English the second
one how would you say that one out loud
well it could also be an awkwardness in
the syntax of see it could be the
opportunist of the syntax of sia data as
well I think of it as more natural to
save food and then save up a signature
of fluids but hot or not allowed to
write that exactly so this is the
mismatches with the way that you think
with the way that the programming
language wants you to write a thickness
indeed anyone have an idea for the next
one
so I would say three plus five x 70 k
times seven okay i would say open paren
3 plus buying clothes for any time zone
okay so three different ways to say this
some people said also said three plus
five point of view times seven so it
came in a bunch of the cases they
mentioned the closed paren but didn't
mention the open / in some cases these
pausing and I'll gets back as that's
actually really interesting there were
some other problems with what people
said most of the time they didn't say
the dot in system dot out dot print line
sometimes we did I have like five times
in the paper code and they would say
different ways every single time there
were lots of different ways to say an
array reference so far sub I bar of I or
actually a good one from usually from
people from India said I from bar
non-native English speakers and English
speakers said things very differently
also so non-native English speakers
almost never pronounced a teraz turf
they always spelled it out so partial
words were always spelled out by
non-native English speakers same thing
for print line I know that's an
abbreviation I know where the word
boundaries are but a non-native English
speaker usually said println finally the
last one is actually an issue in pro
study so the difference between these
two to a native English speaker is array
sub I plus plus and array sub I plus
plus where there's a pause in between
different places in the code a
non-native English speaker when
encountering this ambiguity usually said
take the I fella method of array and had
one to it not this really it's a little
less ambiguous and actually that
actually helps us quite a bit because
with our commercial speech recognition
tools we don't get any timing
information we certainly don't get any
pitch information all we get is the
words that people said so having these
alternative phrasings for these words
allows us to sort of support both more
developers as well as actually handling
these kinds of ambiguous situations
where native English speaker wouldn't
have thought that there would be an
ambiguity with my hands and before I met
with other side biologically as humans
we could talk the whole day or am I
going to help the marble effect of RSA
if I do programming with my mouth so the
verbal equivalent is called voice dream
twice voice rain great voice train yeah
so I'm like repetitive strain injury so
voice straight that's a problem for
people who are new to voice recognition
usually if you're going to be using
voice recognition for a long period of
time your undergo a training period
where they teach you both how to speak
quietly and not very I take frequent
breaks essentially not talk very often
so it's the same thing kind of for
coding like you don't really code
constantly typing for eight hours a day
you kind of get up every so often at
least you have to go to the bathroom you
kind of get up and like look at your
email when it comes in you type your
instant messages so you're not always
doing the coding which actually is sort
of very similar to studies of how people
do bytecodes voice channel will make you
purchase and not be able to talk for
like a day it's like Mary guys
that could be a problem
so what we did after we did the study is
we took that information and we helped
use it to design a new variant of Java
that we call spoken Java which is what
we hope is a more natural way to code
then the and the voice code that
environment so we've got our for loop
and we want people to say for any
cuisine at less than 10 I plus plus now
when we have a computer understand this
we run into some more problems well
because what i just said actually could
be interpreted as foreign t equals 0 I
less than 10 i plus plus nobody said how
to spell any of those words it's for a
keyword or a number how do you spell I
and is then a keyword or identifier
depending on how I spell it it changes
the meaning but of course oh well you
know I'm a human I could eyeball that
that's easy enough but you know what
about this one so how would I say that
out loud okay well for x equals 8 file
to load x equals 1 okay or but that
could be interpreted as for x equals 8
file to load x equals 1 or 4 x equals 8
file to load equals 1 so the same verbal
utterance can come out with lots of
different interpretations so the real
question is how do you fix that and how
do you get rid of that and the answer is
to use the program context and all
throughout the talk i'll show how that
works speech recognition I mean you have
the same problem and you use sentence
structures and stuff
in natural speech recognition they used
to use try to use grabbers and semantic
analysis to understand everything
quickly realize that one the grammar for
English was like a bazillion productions
and that they didn't understand what
people were talking about anyway so they
couldn't figure out which words that
they really did mean Brown basements you
know you do have a learning phase and
you know these students appear next to
each other more often so that's a
sophistical learning approach which is
what they usually do now for English one
of the advantages of programming over a
natural language is that we actually
understand completely the semantic
analysis to make me understand exactly
the program that you're writing because
the compiler eventually has to
understand it so if you're writing in a
program that already exists which is the
typical for programmers you can actually
completely constrain what the
interpretations could be
so there's a design trade-off between
the language we understand which is is
this language a command language or is
this a natural language now if this is a
command language it's much more like
insert a for loop it's going to have a
variable name that variable I and you're
going to have very specific commands for
for putting in pieces of that for loop
and it turns out that you know command
languages are really easy to analyze
because they're very constrained but
they're very the problem is that they're
very constrained and they're very
difficult to learn natural languages is
obviously really hard like if I wanted
to say you know count from one to ten I
can think of at least 50 different ways
to say count from one to 10 including
count from 0 to 9 if I'm being really
picky especially if the computer
language is supposed to figure out that
i really mean count from 0 and put 10 in
the second slot and not die so natural
languages are really flexible but
obviously very ambiguous so the
trade-off where we want to be as
somewhere in the middle something that's
actually easy to say but analyzable by a
computer so what we built is the spoken
java it's semantically identical to java
because when we try to help programmers
we don't get to dictate what their
coding what their code is at the end of
the day at the end of the day it's their
boss who says you shall program in C++
now it's our job to sort of make it
easier for them to get the seatpost bus
into the computer but not to say you
need to program in our whiz-bang new
programming language that we've just
made up special for voice so spoken job
is syntactically easier to say than Java
and the kind of methodology we used is
generalizable to other programming
languages to give them a little
illustration of a high-level overview of
what it is all punctuation has English
equivalents and open brace some of them
are context-sensitive like end the for
loop or end the class that's what most
people said punctuation is all optional
completely and utterly you don't have to
say it there's verbalizations for every
abbreviation in the language and every
abbreviation that you'll find in the API
it's sort of a general support for
abbreviations in general and also we
modified some of the production's to be
a little bit easier to say in English
such as the cast operator where you can
say cast food to integer instead of the
other way around you can say
assignment with a sign through the six
crew gets sick set through 26 and also
this already reference operation yeah
more number of programs in seamlessness
company for general why do they choose
young man whispers Salva is smaller and
easier to analyze and for a dissertation
project is tractable so it's not a
question of you know we don't like C++
or we don't feel it's a relevant problem
it's more that I only have so many nurse
to do it I mean can you give me an
example of an analysis which you can do
for Java which you will not be able to
do a successful I might be able to but I
would let me think about it for a while
I'll talk to you after so what we do
with this programming languages we put
it into an editor so we have our editors
called speed it supports this naturally
verbalized input form speed stands for
speech editor and is also catchy we use
off-the-shelf commercial speech
recognizer originally movies IBM via
voice but we're thinking about switching
to Dragon NaturallySpeaking we stick our
programming environment into eclipse
because it's not really fun to write an
editor over again and we use a lot of
analysis infrastructure that comes from
the Harmonia research project which
we'll talk about next so we've got
spoken java language for composition
we've got a smokin command language for
dealing with editing navigation template
instantiation and transformations search
and we want to incorporate some audible
and visual feedback to handle the
problems where when you're speaking you
generally have problems with you you
have less capacity in your short-term
memory something a bench dynamite kind
of figured out and if you were this talk
yesterday who might have said something
like that so by incorporating some
visual feedback you helped you remind
the user what they're about to say
audible feedback helps train the user on
what's allowed to be said so you can
highlight something and say how do you
say this out loud so there's similar to
a Java speak project at winona state
university so harmonia is a project I
worked on since i started in graduate
school at sort of in a program analysis
infrastructure designed for incremental
for interactive programming tools and so
a lot of the analyses are incremental
it's got your favorite lexer parser
semantic analysis and it supports a
whole bunch of different languages we
don't do c++ yet
which is another reason why we didn't do
supposed to us here see actually Steve
in the audience actually did RC
implementation which is very cool and
Java titanium which is a parallel
superset of Java cool we can also hand
the languages where white space is
important such as like your pythons we
do flex and bison because we those are
important for language designers her
money also does interactive program
transformations code link is a way to
manage your code when it's duplicated
then you can't abstract it into a
function or you just don't want to and
shorthand anything I'll talk about a
little bit later who's also originally
conceived of by the sched a day who's
also an intern here at Microsoft seems
to everybody is coming to Microsoft so
maybe that means something okay so let's
tell you how it works a traditional
compiler consists of three pieces at
least the front end of a compiler which
is lexical analysis where you take
characters and turn them into words
parsing where you take those words and
turn them into program structures and
then semantic analysis where you
actually figure out what those words
mean and you do name resolution names
and uses and definitions and you also do
type checking and figure out whether the
program is correct so all this works for
unambiguous programming languages where
you know exactly what the user typed in
now what we've done is extended it to
support ambiguities that come from human
speech so first we take our lexical
analysis and we make it support
homophones I think words that sounded
like but are spelled differently they
come in from human speech we have an
ambiguous parsing algorithm which is
able to take those homophones and also
more much more ambiguous grammar for
Java and turn that into possible program
structures and then we use semantic
analysis to help figure out which of
those possible structures possible
interpretations are legal and get rid of
the illegal ones so just a little more
detail we use a commercial speech
recognizer we pass it to a home phone
dictionary that I snarf off the web that
has really cool how phones some of them
are dialectical so like if you're from
New York and you say draw DRA wer that's
the synonym for draw i like that
homophones experience you basically look
up a word and it tells you all the words
in sound alike and then we run it
through our lexer to figure out what
those boys me now some of the problems
that you can get with the with the
analysis are if you say for I equals
well that actually could mean lots of
different things for it could be spelled
for different ways I I didn't say how to
spell it and equals could also be equals
equals and you just didn't say double
equals and you could have the spell that
word or you can have the symbol now in
addition to the fact that you can have
different spellings I also didn't tell
you where the word boundaries go so I
could have 4i as just a single
identifier I could have the whole thing
be one gigantic word I could have also
actually I didn't tell you where the
Capitals were capital letters I didn't
tell you where the abbreviations were
you know there's all sorts of things
that are lexical in nature that that
don't come out from human voice that do
effective compiler so once we get all
those possibilities we pass them all on
a to our parser and what we do in
parsing is we're based our algorithm off
g LR parsing that's generalized LR
parsing developed in around 85 at
Carnegie Mellon by tomita it's okay if
you don't know what I can explain how
the parser sort of works in general
terms so yeah you guys can follow what
the differences are between my algorithm
in this original one so in our parser
we've got it nested if statement here
and so we want to parse it so the first
thing we do is we Lex everything and we
move our if keyword over into our parse
then we take our predicate expression
and move it into the parcel moving
things over to the left is moving things
into the parse then we take our next if
we move it into the parts are next
predicate and then we have food now if
expression foo is actually a perfectly
legitimate whole if statement because I
don't really need an else but I don't
really know yet which one I should pick
so in normal parsers you pick one you
always say move the else into the
closest if statement but in a GL our
parts we don't have to make that choice
we can actually do something different
we can fork our parser into two possible
paths one of them says that if
expression foo
is a statement and that this little
statement is done and the other one
doesn't say that so what I'll do is I'll
continue both parses at the same time
and so i'll move else into both parses
and i'll move bar into both parses and
now at the top I've got if expression
foo else bar so that's a statement to
and notice that's a different statement
than the one on the bottom now if I
complete the part I get a second
statement up there and I get a statement
up there there are two different parcels
for the same set of words they both have
the same yield which is really important
and actually in reality these two
parcels are not we don't four threads
that would be crazy we do a lot of
structural sharing we do a lot of
sharing of the parse state itself we do
a lot of sharing of the parse of the
yield of the parts of the tokens and the
sub trees that are make up the parse
tree young question bars in there but it
must have been a split that happened a
little before balls oh right right after
yes I'll explain that this is this is
the algorithm back to not support home
phones so in my next thing I'll talk
about the homophones yeah yes so what
about it both about that's fine
yes
that's why it's ambiguous so it no I
don't need to joke it's it's a question
in most programming languages when you
write your grammar the analysis tools
going to tell you you have in this case
a reduced reduced conflict and you're
supposed to have to fix that manually
and most people fix that by saying
prefer the top solution for the top
carcery so that the bottom one never
exists so I was just giving an example
just to show that there is an ambiguity
alright so what's important with GL r is
that whenever there's a structural
ambiguous the parser will fork and try
out both possibilities and in which case
that actually can fork many times
depending on how much ambiguity there is
and what's also important to it is that
that ambiguity is bounded locally so
that it does not fork excessively for
long periods of time and that eventually
it does have the ability to merge back
together into single parchers when
they're the ambiguities over whenever
there's no ambiguity it's order n in
time and whenever there is ambiguity
it's order n cube and but it's always
essentially order N squared space so the
thing that i did is i added the ability
for the parser to fork when there's
lexical ambiguity when there are
homophones on the input so let me show
you how that works so we've got an
example if 55 is less than X all right
so this is a sort of a partial if
statement just to get going because it's
pretty big this is work that's published
in the ldt a last year so first thing we
do is we're going to lecture our input
word so if is a key word and we'll move
it into our parse just like we did last
time now we want to Lex 55 well what is
55 55 could be two words 50 and five but
are both identifiers it could be 50 as a
word and five as a number or the
opposite they both could be numbers or
they could actually be a concatenated
number so lots of different
interpretations just for one word what
we're going to do is we're going to I'm
going to move that into the parson
election I'm going to show it as a
replicated parse on the Left notice
actually on the right our input stream
is now mostly the same length except
this one this input stream only has two
tokens in it not three so that's
actually kind of important you pay
attention to that so now what we do is
we've got our identifiers in the input
and some numbers well after an
identifier in spoken Java you can kind
of have a lot of punctuation you can
have an open print or a dot so let's
replicate those parses and we'll pretend
that we inserted an open plan or a dot
and I'm replicating the bottom two
parses twice beach okay and now of
course you got replicate the right side
the input again we don't actually
replicate anything it's just for
illustration purposes so now what we
want to do is we want to take our next
layer of input and move it into the
parse but not everything is going to par
successfully actually so what happens at
the top is you're saying if 50 dot five
and well that's not really legal you're
not allowed to have a number after a dot
if the thing that came before it is not
a number you can have two tokens kind of
separated by spaces in this language
either two numbers or identifiers
followed by numbers so we get rid of the
gray parses and what I'm gonna do now is
just I'm going to get rid of those who
move everything else down so let's pop
those down to the bottom so now I'm left
with a bunch of parses and and again you
know I have an identifier so I can have
a brand dot or in this case now closed
paren because I had an open paren before
so now replicate it again get out a lot
more parses and I'll take my input token
which is the less than except for the
bottom one which is you know x I'll Lex
that so everything's about operator
except for the bottom and then I'll move
that into the parts and of course lots
of them died again because you can't
have to punctuation tokens kind of next
to each other like that so I'll get rid
of those by the way this job 14 not 15
and pretend you don't need a print at
the end beginning idiot so we'll get rid
of those and then what we've got now is
the ability to that Lex our last input
token and notice the bottom one is
already done doesn't have to keep going
and we move it into the part ok and now
let's show you sort of what the
different Parsons might be so I'll
spread these out on the screen and we'll
go from the bottom up the first one says
if 55 is less than X that one's nice
that's an expression if 50.5 is less
than X that's not really done so I'm
get a I'm just going to put those away
from now the next one above is if 50 dot
5 is less than x which is probably not
something you would have expected but
since nobody says dot it could have been
if 55 is less than X well if 50 is a
method call and five is its argument and
it's perfectly legal then that would be
a great interpretation and then finally
a 55 where five is a number and being
passed into the method so all these
interpretations are actually pretty
legitimate except when we try to figure
out which ones are legal one of the big
ones yes and then you would have you
know 50 being a function ball which
takes in a bully yes philos the next you
didn't do that one yes because I think
at the example where they continue that
oh all right so notice the big thing
here is all these parse trees now do not
have the same yield the bottom of the
parse tree is not the same and we've
also been you know forking our parts are
based on all these multiple homophones
and missing punctuation so the X glr
that's what we call this algorithm is a
generalization of gr g lr that supports
this kind of forking on lexical
ambiguity as well as the structural
ambiguity what I kept mentioning about
that whole the yield problem being very
different across multiple parses we
actually do a lot of effort to make sure
that you preserve the structural sharing
that GL r has with the yield otherwise
you would get exponential space instead
of N squared space in your parse and
also notice that I told you before the
Parsons got out of sync one parts
finished earlier than the others what's
really important in this in this
analysis mode is basically if one part
of gets ahead of the others when those
parts is kind of start they don't want
them replicating work that the one that
got ahead of already did so you need to
be able to support parser merging which
is another feature of GL are even
despite the fact that those parcels
might be out of sync and so that's other
challenges we have to face and fixed we
built blender which is a combined
lecture and parser analysis partial
generator and actually that this is sort
of a key piece that you can need to in
this work combined the lecture and the
parser generator together
in order to understand these ambiguities
because a lot of what the parser does is
direct the lecture to do particular
things when there's an ambiguity instead
of just having a feed-forward system so
there's feedback from the parson to the
lexer an example of that is for we can
deal with embedded languages such as
like bison where you've got a regular
expression followed by a code in C code
now the boundary between the regular
expression and the C code which is two
different languages and two different
lexical definitions is white space
sometimes it's an open brace and often
that means that the boundary between
those two languages is ambiguous so we
might be lexing in two different
languages at the same time in which case
the parser kind of needs to tell the
lecture which language still flexing
yeah sure fit into the rest of the
pipeline is it the case that it produces
a bunch of parse trees and then the
semantic analysis that follows them
rejects even more of them tries to find
one last one that will work yes and I'll
that's the next but okay that by the
same token you would argue that you want
to have
my neck so far and semantic now is true
okay when there is a generator not the
analysis itself so there's a different
picture in language people's an electric
arc generator which generates tables
versus the runtime system which actually
does the parsing it does the lexing so
the runtime system is actually very
traditional there's a lecture there's a
parser sometimes the parser kind of
tells the lecture what to do but not
very often and then that all those
results are passed off to the separate
semantic analysis so they're still
modeling for the most part the
generators just so that the par States
know more about what lecture state
you're supposed to be in just a little
genealogy for those who are interested
to mediate invented GL are based on some
weird algorithm by lang in the 70s far
she fixed it records implemented it it
moved off to the netherlands where they
went and decided to get rid of the
lecture entirely and merge it into the
GL our parser in our group wagner made
the algorithm incremental which
basically allows it to be used in an
interactive programming environment
without performance problems I went and
extended for input stream ambiguities
and then aging johnstone this guy from
Britain who's funny well he thinks he's
funny he came up with a new he came up
with a new formalism for like fixing the
GL our parser that tomita came up with
the GL our algorithm that he kind of
likes better and then went off and
started doing all sorts of weird part of
parsing algorithms but he's cool guy ok
anyway look we're up to these semantic
disambiguation at this point is everyone
kind of comfortable anymore questions so
far ok so here's an example of some Java
code that loads a file from a screen ok
and it's pretty generic what I want to
do is at the cursor point i want to add
file to load equal stream don't read
string so i want to read the file name
from the stream and the code that it
should produce when the person says this
is file to load equals stream that reads
drink so that's our goal for this
example ok keep that going mine now the
question is when I say files
load even just those three words I have
so many different interpretations I've
got file where it's a variable I've got
file where it's a method I can spell
load in different ways I've got file to
load there's a single word I'm not
showing you capitalization here so
there's actually more this is just a few
of the possibilities so now how do I
figure out which ones are the right ones
because that's actually pretty important
so what we do is we actually built an
incremental semantic analysis system
because like to build things and it's
able to answer questions of the form
what does this name mean and what names
are visible here or what I like to say
is what can I say here because that's
really useful information for
constraining the domain of the speech
recognition for getting more accurate
speech recognition now what we built is
an extension of the visibility graph
which is a data structure for names
scopes and bindings that was developed
by one of my advisors graduate students
in the 80s and I'm the first person to
find a use for it just very cool
essentially it's incremental II updated
over time so that it doesn't take a long
time to to generate because we kind of
do analysis after every word that comes
in and it we also had to extend it so it
actually worked for name propagation and
for incrementally updating we use this
for type checking now the biggest
advantage of this visibility graph is
going to be order one lookups on names
and i'll show you how that works in a
second but again we could we could say
it doesn't you know my doesn't Visual
Studio do this and I have to customize
that for the audience doesn't Visual
Studio do all this name analysis don't
we have code sense can't you already
look up what the words are and the
really key thing is I can do it faster
from my domain which is being able to do
this after every word now what we have
is we have a graph and this is a really
simplified graph of our example we have
to scope nodes in the graph one for the
class and one for the method and each
one has a set of bindings in it which
say whether all the names that are
visible or defined in the scope so the
first one says in the class I have a
method named load in the method I have
two variables once a file to load which
is a string and one is a stream which is
an input stream now there's a little bit
of propagation so we take the binding
from the
first known and push it down into the
second node and this is an arbitrary
graph so we do a whole big propagation
step to push everything into these nodes
and what you get by pushing all the
variables into a note is an order one
look up on a name because whenever two
named clash we basically pick one that
according to the language semantics is
the one that would have won anyway based
on the name inheritance rules of the
language so with our order one look up
we can now answer all these questions
like is vile a visible variable name
well so I'm looking up this these guys
this file visible variable name I don't
see it anywhere I'm looking up in the
scope here so no so that means those are
not the right possibilities is file a
visible method name again I don't see it
so no it's not so that that one goes
away is file a visible method if file to
load a visible method name well fossil
is visible but it's the local variable
so that's not the right answer and the
last one actually is file to load is a
local variable so that's the one I would
pick so that's how i get rid of all the
others yeah so is this a return to the
basic structure in anything where I have
to do everything in programming language
wants so for example I can't use a
variable before I declare it because
then
recognize that oh so I'll say how to do
a half answer half BSF now some of it is
a return to structure editor just
because it's for two reasons one it's a
dissertation so it's easier and to its
you don't really have a cursor when
you're programming by voice because
you're not just speaking code in a row
it's harder to do that to make a
completely modeless voice-based editor
the other answer is no it's not a
structure-based editor it doesn't have
the flaw where you have to program in a
top-down way because if we can't
disambiguate next slide what we do is we
basically leave the ambiguity around if
we disambiguate incorrectly we leave the
ambiguity around you still can see one
interpretation but if you let's say we
resolved in the ambiguity as we said
fubar and foo is food bar or food method
call with bars and argument and let's
say I intended it to be the method call
but I haven't defined the method yet but
there is a field named true and it does
have a bar subfield that's legitimate so
there was essentially there should be
two legitimate answers but I only saw
one at the the analysis engine only
someone so it resolved it well it
resolved it but if you don't touch it
and then you add your in second method
name foo it will dip on this it'll re
ambigua essentially a fubar back into
its two possibilities because those are
now two things that are legal now you
just have to train the user not to touch
it when they see is that it's wrong
that's part of the training but let me
get to that because the training comes
asked if the user types at it with a
keyboard we assume that that's
unambiguous and he really means what he
says so if he fixes food a bar into food
/ n bar closed paren then she went and
all the ambiguity there goes away
in your environment then you could
multiple yes then you could have
ambiguity and then you could go resolve
it later so you could first you could
you could you could first do the use and
you can later go do the definition and
that definition could resolve the
ambiguity thing that so that's that's
quite different than structured you
structured editing where if you do use
without a definition it just complains
and it doesn't let you put anything in
that was partly why I gave that path
hands okay okay but then you can't
really throw away those parse there's no
readouts right but been in the previous
slide you just wait right so you can't
wait through it what happens is
basically we have a data structure
called and a big ambiguity node that has
all the possible Parsons underneath and
knows which one is the currently
selected parchment and we visualize that
overruled yeah they can change at any
time as the user decides to pay
come on so you to use it a lot of space
right minify how my stuff yeah so the
space issue is an important thing and we
address that with the user interface and
I'll talk about that in a sec so we do
have some ambiguities that are not
resolvable such as print line or this
nested if statement where you don't
really want to decide for the user what
the semantics are so we just leave those
alone if the ambiguities do remain what
we do is we allow the user to kind of
pick and that's based on some of the
ambiguity mediation stuff from Jim
mankatha so I want to do navigation that
editing that we're kind of running short
on time so I might skip a few things but
we'll be okay I did another study in one
of the classes I took on how people
navigate using voice recognition tools
and what I had them do I didn't want
them to just use the fine tool to look
for a word because you know it's kind of
bogus what I wanted them to do is to
look for something that didn't really
know exactly what they were looking for
but they'd note when they saw it which
is a lot of times very similar to what
you're doing with coding you know
exactly know what you're looking for but
you'll recognize it so what I did is I
took romeo and juliet and i said look
for the place where Romeo cries out
after killing Tybalt you know in act 2
scene 1 or seeing three or something
like that so you can't really search for
Romeo because he talks a lot and you
can't really search for word Tybalt
stops talking because that's not
something search tools usually give you
so you kind of have to scroll through
and using the speech recognition command
so if go down five lines go down ten
lines go down 20 lines keep going page
down page down and of course most future
conacher's force you to pause in between
you saying two commands in the Royal
page down page down it's you know it's
very slow so we tried to come up with a
better way that wasn't always better but
we learned something so we said how long
does it take to do this how many
commands have to come out of your mouth
to make this happen how often because
you're saying these commands doesn't get
it wrong now what we did find is the
cognitive load of searching is
incredibly high what you're usually
doing is reading at the same time as
when you're trying to control a system
what we had is an auto-scrolling system
which was worse it basically scrolled a
certain velocity and that you can
control it with saying faster
lower it turned out that humans can't
read unless this text is stopped so we
came up with a scroll and stop system
which then you control the length of the
pause but the problem is that voice
recognition has a huge delay it's about
a one-second delay between the time you
say something and the time it reacts to
you so if you're going through at any
fast enough speed to sort of see things
see something read it and spot it and
then say stop by the time you said stop
it's already gone like four pages ahead
so it's like your TiVo when you press
fast forward them to do you know it goes
ahead and then when you press play it
jumps back a little bit now they figured
out how to get that exact because I'm
impressed for the most part I can't do
the three fast-forwards I can only do
too it takes a Jedi Master they get to
three-month correct but in our system we
didn't have any timing information that
when the voice actually came into the
microphone so we couldn't even do this
at all usefully we found there were a
lot of commands that people have to say
there were too many errors and we
society you know you really do need to
customize your voice recognition
commands for the environment and what
you're working so we did is we built
some navigation and editing commands to
make our system a little bit more usable
now first I could describe shorthand
editing which is from JJ over there in
the corner as our undergraduate came up
with the idea as a freshman and we
joined our group and implemented it with
harmonia short anything is a way of
essentially doing a structural kind of
edit on your tree so when you get us a
structural cursor that you can move
around the tree by saying like down and
up and down and left and right then what
you could do is once you're editing up
once you're kind of on a particular word
you can say things like protected or
private and it will basically replace
the words that are prop that are correct
with the with the other possibilities
for the for what things could be put
into that statement if I said static
that would have actually added the word
not just replace the word that I was
currently looking at now in addition to
being able to edit I could also move
down and let's say I want them to take
that line it and move it down to the
next line it's kind of swap it with the
one below it so I would say like push
down
and that essentially takes that line and
moves it down the screen so it's a
little bit more its constant cognizance
of structure in your program it's
continent of the statements of the words
and what they can do is basically allow
you to operate on larger entities than
just characters which is something
really nice for programs now in addition
think down down down down down down down
is really long especially if you're kind
of scrolling through your document so I
came up with a faster way of doing a
sort of really quick navigation which is
called contest sensitive mouths grid
what you do is we number all the classes
that come up on the screen when you say
mouse grid so we've got numbers there
and then all you have to do is read the
number off for where it's pointing and
you say 113 select and it hierarchically
navigates into your code and then
selects a line that you perhaps want to
edit so I'll say edit and what it'll do
is it'll take this code turn it into
spoken Java from Java so which is on the
bottom there file to load equals quote
file that text quote whenever we
translate it from Java the spoken Java
we add all the punctuation it just
because it's easier to read and then we
display it with the punctuation ok so in
which get you no punctuation that's got
to be there in Java anyway so then the
person might say file to load equals
stream dot read string and put it back
and because we know where it's going we
know how to analyze it in context and we
use the context of the program to figure
out which one's the legal interpretation
and which is what we have there so
that's how the whole system finley works
let's say there was a complex expression
plus I beg times yes replace the plus
with time and I would read the whole
thing and sale and repeat it with dice
so two answers one you can edit
structures as small as you want so if it
was five times six or five plus six you
could get down to the five plus six and
only have to say that part again you
can't just say the operator right now
and the other thing is when you restate
it it's bringing down the original text
into your editor and at that point
you're using kind of your normal voice
recognition tools for playing with that
which allows you to actually
like that start and edit it and change
it to a plus as text now the key thing
about this user interface that's nice is
that it fixes our ambiguity problem or
ambiguity blow-up problem so you say
lots of words in a row let's say I don't
know 50 words or so and you get like
five bazillion ambiguities that's
obviously a problem for any analysis
system but if I only let you type into a
one line thing that's only this big you
know you can't fit that many words in
there so you can't overwhelm the system
with too many things to say and in which
case you probably don't want to be
saying way too many things anyway just
because you want to see the results of
what's happening as you edit now this is
sort of an edge style editor this is
like very retro it's tractable for a
dissertation you know if you were making
this like kind of robust and
power-hungry you paint this more like VI
or emacs or something or something
perhaps even better actually I was going
to say this reminds me of VI because
there's this navigation mode and then
there's this text entry gap right so the
thing that people always hated about the
eye is there was no visible indication
as to which mode you looking so is the
yellow highlighter here or something my
my indicator in the UI is well the
yellow highlighter is the navigation
cursor when you edit it you do get a
little like kind of text box on the
bottom which is where you're currently
typing so you're not really it's it's
actually really more like Ed because in
VI once you say I for insert you can
actually do any text editing on that
line this actually is much more
constrained where you're editing
structures and only being able to type
that particular structure
so the recognition error recovery is
something that we just use the stuff
that comes from the dragon so it's
actually a training problem which I'll
get to in the next step so our study
we're doing a study to see how people
use this and next month and we want to
train programmers on speed and one of
the things that you have to train them
for is when the system makes a
recognition when the system appears to
have made a recognition mistake there's
a class of mistakes that are mistakes
real mistakes and then there's class of
mistakes which are things like that the
system just doesn't have enough
information to resolve an ambiguity or
perhaps resolved it wrong because of a
used F perhaps spelled something around
but spelled it consistently so it would
still compile but maybe they said for I
equals 1 to 10 and it used a ye and they
really want I and the system at that
point we need to train developers not to
touch it because it'll eventually get it
right and it's similar to what you have
to do to train people for normal speech
recognition is that you can use speech
recognition to dictate a document you
could just start dictating and watch the
words come up on the screen but it tends
to slow you down a lot and every time
you see an error you want to fix it
right away which also makes you forget
about where you were going to say
because you usually that stops you too
much it interrupts you and pin
successful speech recognizer users don't
look when they're saying something and
they dictate like a whole sentence or a
whole paragraph before they look and try
to correct the one true mistakes same
thing I think is going to be true for
this programming project except on the
larger granularity you want to be able
to say more of your program and then
only before you want to compile it do
you want to thank fix the errors and
maybe there's a trade-off in time there
that's something we'll have to look at
when we actually start training people
to use this
baby this is there any like visual
indication or is there any way that you
can turn a cycle through them to exactly
yeah annotation underline a little
squiggly in a certain color and then you
can click on it to get a pop-up window
popup menu to show all the possible
interpretations in big one that's JJ's
can do this summer ok so our training is
basically build some new code like a
data structure that's something that
even novice programmers should be able
to do after their first computer science
class and write some algorithms that go
along with it like reversing a linked
list and then we want to test also
editing so I want to see how it works
for that for authoring where you don't
have a lot of context and for editing
where you do now things we're looking at
our you know of course speed because
everybody wants to know have fast or
slow you go the kind of mistakes that
you make when you forget what you can
say or you forget how to say something
like what how non-intuitive is the
language despite having done a user
study so this is the kind of things you
want to get irate over also metrics on
how often does it figure out where the
word boundaries are incorrectly how
often does it disambiguate incorrectly
and how often do you get these
irresolvable ambiguities where you get
like these nested if statements where
you don't really know exactly what to do
if that happens all the time this is
going to be a completely unworkable
system I'm not sure it's going to have
to that's why we're doing the study now
finally I just want to sort of sum up
and tell you sort of what I did again
just to remind you so first we do a
study of programmers we figured out what
they would say if they could speak code
out loud and then we design an
interactive editor that will support
this kind of spoken in platform so we
designed a spoken language and we
designed the analyses extended a lot of
compiler analyses to understand the
spoken language which is very similar to
programming languages and then are able
to analyze this form and put it into the
editor and we designed some user
interface techniques to go along with it
then we evaluate our design or we'll be
evaluating next month our design and the
two
for using the system so before I go to
that does anybody have any questions now
on the program by boy stuff yes usually
when you proba you don't you know
exactly what will be your program so you
multiply your design or your code along
the way
and you will pause you will have some
strong and yes each of this language and
you also want to sync sometimes you want
to confuse the encourages to know what
okay so Paul are those kind of issues
so it's similar to the session that had
with Rob about whether this is a
structure editor or not start credit is
very prescriptive in the way that they
require you the code in a particular way
I top down and know what you're coding
before the coding you know what all
functions going to be called or what
functions you need the our system is a
lot more freeform we're based on some
technology that allows you to have
erroneous and incomplete programs still
be analyzable so you could program and
kind of pretty much anywhere you want
our system might find it more troubling
to analyze something without any context
because of all the ambiguities that
might be there but you can still choose
the disambiguate them yourself and the
positive and other stuff when we get to
that after the talk yeah weights basic
comment program that's being injured so
white space is we kind of pretty print
the program if you're saying it by voice
and comments come when you we can just
turn out normal dictation support from
the program from the speech recognizer
to be able to say you say comments and
then you can just talk for a while all
right so let's get to sort of future
work where could this go were someone to
continue working on programming by voice
and not to say I'm you know potentially
not working on it but you know I'm
bitter but I like my stuff so okay the
first thing we could do is look at
symantec disambiguation a lot of what I
do is pretty much just take all the
different ambiguities and type check
each one and say which one is correct
now I think you could use some ideas
from machine learning and from natural
language processing like their stuff
that they tried to do in the 60s for
English and adapt it may be adapted for
44 disambiguation of of programming
languages where you do have the complete
semantic domain the other thing I want
to do is try to learn a little bit about
how you program because if you always
say four NTA equals zero and that always
is a for loop there shouldn't be no
ambiguity there so if the system can
learn from the user then they can help
do that the other thing is we do a
feed-forward system of ambiguous
occation if that's a word and that leads
to quite a few
you ambiguities that make it's a
semantic analysis that are required to
be interpreted which is why I have to
cut down on the size of the input but
you could imagine taking information
about the program you already have like
semantic analysis and passing it along
to the lecture and saying well you know
fubar mu is not an identifier in my
program so that's unless you're to have
just said the word declare and you're
trying to declare a new variable this is
not likely to be the right one so you
can get rid of some ambiguities early
the other thing I want to look at is
sort of higher-level linguistic
programming tools will be found from
when people were talking speaking their
code if some people talked about the
code and not just said the code out lab
and some people talked about in a cool
way so if the code said food that a
equals 0 food be equal zero Fuji equals
zero two people said set all the fields
of food to zero which is cool because
that's shorter and that means if you can
support that kind of slightly higher
level this course you could actually
make the programmer a little bit more
productive especially in the voice world
where they're probably gonna be a lot
slower than the typist using the system
also phonetic search one of the problems
with the find dialog when you're using
the voice is when you say like find
fubar and it spells it wrong and you're
like scratch that and it right so I'll
scratch that and then you say no correct
that and right side correct that and
you're like no fix the spelling and then
it says how do you want to spell scratch
and you're like no and a lot of people
cancel the find dialog and start over
again whenever they make an error so you
get a lot of cascaded there's if fine
we're phonetic then you sure you'd find
more things but that's conservative at
least you could do is just find a whole
bunch of things and then you'll pick
which one is right also the audible
feedback is going to help a lot with
training because you'll be able to
highlight something and say how do you
say this now you could also look into
supporting other types of task by voice
debugging I the rest of the IDE comments
common thing by voice is kind of neat
for if you imagine for a code review I
could just like get caught your copy of
code talk about it and that I don't
actually have to meet with you well you
know unless I want feedback and all but
at least you could do is like they're
contextualized so you just kind of
embedded kind of like a tablet pc
journal program you could also design
spoken variants of lots of other
programming languages like C C++
csharp other types of design languages
from robotics languages maybe some SQL
this could revolutionize the idea of
programming you know code based on voice
anyway no probably well okay so uh
whereby I go yes the differences between
Java and Java speak oh so Java speak is
output it's when you say the code out
loud only it's for it was developed for
blind programmers to sort of be able to
have them understand what the code that
is that they're writing by speaking it
back to them so let me take that offline
because I think there might be a
mismatch between spoken Java Java and
Java speak and I might be answering one
question so okay thanks so where I won't
want to go is I really think there's a
rich interaction history that happens
between the programmer in the
development environment and there's
absolutely no reason why that should not
be captured and used to help the
programmer such as let's say i don't
know i was editing some code and i
checked in a week later and now i don't
remember what I did because like I
checked it I fix the least a few things
but if you knew what the program had
been doing maybe he'd been editing a
function maybe he'd been adding a field
maybe he'd been fixing bugs number 42
you could start grabbing all that
information and start grabbing through
the bug database and start looking
through the email documents to figure
out old maybe you were catching this bug
if you fix this bug and helped write the
CVS message for the developer you could
also do task in France and start
figuring out like instead of having low
level keyboard data you kind of want to
figure out what does that mean what was
the developer really trying to do
because then you could build tools that
help them with casts that they're trying
to view and also coding guides like if
there's a certain way the people in your
if there's a certain way the people in
your organization code there's a certain
style that they have maybe you want to
learn from somebody who's expert and
you're a new guy on the team you know
you want to somehow take advantage of
the fact that you want to tell a data
mind his programming stream and say well
every time he calls a function he always
checks the eight result well maybe when
I could I should always check the eight
results you so in addition I also want
to look at
code programming communication like when
I'm talking to you in the you know room
with the whiteboard and at the end of
the hall in the lounge and we're talking
about the code maybe we have the code in
front of us maybe we don't how do we
know that we're talking about the same
things how do we express ourselves how
does the program i talk about code it's
kind of a natural extension of talking
about itself but there's no I think
there's pretty much no related work in
this area there's a lot of work on
programmer comprehension here's a page
of code tell me what it means but
there's very little work in saying how
do you talk about this piece of code so
i want to learn a lot about that that
could also help you with capturing
design history for long live pieces of
code the code that blass that that
expands a lot of division developers
code that's really big fine I'm a new
person coming out to a project how do I
know where to start well usually I'll go
and ask somebody who's smart who already
worked on this code for a long time but
what if that guy is in Nepal what if
he's on vacation or what if she's left
the company what if he's moved on I
don't have the right resources and even
when I do get the right resources they
just tell me stuff and I just keep it so
there's no capture of this kind of of
this kind of knowledge about the program
and that's something you really do I
kind of want to fix now another weird
project is sort of i call programming in
the large so what does it mean if you
could have a whiteboard to program on
like a lot of my friends take their code
they print the entire thing on paper and
they spread it out in the floor and they
say okay well this function calls this
function over here and this one calls
this one and now i understand what my
code is doing well I want to look at
visualizations that could take advantage
of a lot of that space if you have very
large programs you need a very large
space to look at it without anything
really clever now also sort of a pet
peeve of mine has always been I never
know what my compiler is doing if I have
a scientific programmer on compiling
code and I really care what the
optimizer that it unrolls this loop four
times that it assigns this this variable
into a register and that and that this
code I really think is dead but I need
to have it in my coat well how do I find
that out if I'm a compiler hacker I go
and look at the assembly code and then I
say okay well i know this assembly code
back maps this source code and let me
figure out what it does and then if I
tweak the source code a little bit I can
make the compiler unroll it one more
time you know that's lame especially for
people who most programmers haven't
taken part a compiler class especially
domain experts like scientific
programmers really have been taken apart
of classes they have a dick and
programming classes so they don't really
have a hope of this what I want to do is
try to visualize some of these optimizer
results some of these program analysis
results in the editor itself and show
the user like a representation of their
code that says look it's unrolled four
times because you can actually see it
four times in a row or highlight dead
coding gray that says oh this code looks
dead and just show that as they're
editing so that they are aware of what's
going on this also has to be scalable
and that's actually really important
because your programs are big most
programs are you know hundred thousand
million lines of code and control flow
graphs and parse trees and things like
that they're just completely useless
unless you know both what you're going
to do with them and also you find some
way of filtering out the information to
just the stuff that you care about yeah
characters J my toe that I can handle um
no not you can handle what is it not
just program your it and what is the
length of the program but then you are
written using your tone Oh risen using
my phone I'm wondering is it poss coming
can it what are the effects if I use
this tool for two months on my program
and productivity I don't know that yet
so what is a Samaritan using this I've
only ever in really small burger because
oh yeah 50 20 lines this contested you
know started getting to the point where
it's trying to be ended so I'm getting
it to work one of that fixing bugs at
this point in trying it out that's what
I want to do tests the user tests
another project I want to do is sort of
looking at scalable debugging how do you
do bug concurrent applications when you
have lots of threads because I certainly
do not appreciate putting up 15 gdb
windows and typing next next next day
and printing out 15 different variables
15 times or even just seeing a big
gigantic array variable because if I
have a program that's running out of
eight thousand processors there's no way
I can understand that I need a
statistical debugging thing I need to be
able to ask stupid Aquarius I need to be
able to say things like break point when
three processors have different values
for this variable you know that's not
something you can easily say in a
command-line debugger or even something
like visual studio the bugger but it's
something that's really important when
you have these large programs even
concurrent applications of just like a
couple threads are still get annoying to
debug and so that's something I think
would be really interesting to look at
so that's it that's over and you can ask
me any questions you want I could leave
this on the screen if that's interesting
for you
no I can't not right here the tool only
works on my computer in my office
because of licensing issues in because
it's the only fast pc i have it works on
windows only right now unfortunately it
used to run on my mac and the ISA
violently
it keeps the desktop speech recognition
is kind of dead so all the vendors
taking away their tools it's very
frustrating is that Senator with us
yeah speech recognition for desktop
users for people who use like a
dictation on the thing that's really
winning is that is speech recognition
for a fee for telephony so if you call
it the United Airlines and you say I
want a flight from you know Zimbabwe to
her are like this since the same country
but yeah but that kind of thing being
able to understand that is where all the
resources going why lots of money we
save money when you don't have the
operators when you're off human
operators handling phone calls
oh why is it dead because it has to be
kind of it was a little over hype so the
problems are that that it's really
difficult to control your computer by
talking about it it's really difficult
to replace a mouse by verbal
communication these are being able to
point it something like if you were to
hear tell me where this is using your
voice you know it's a couple inches over
from here it's a couple inches up humans
are really bad at estimating distance so
it taps into everything that humans are
bad at so what this is doing to see
because I'm actually looking at how so
two things one I'm tackling a population
for which there's not many other choices
so it's sort of more compelling for that
reason and it's also something where I'm
trying to look at how they might use it
more effectively to improve upon generic
use of voice recognition to the desktop
and say customized explicitly for
programming how do we adapt this tool
and provide tools that really are are
specific for the problems that
programmers are going to have
your voice you just use their detect
general education model I use their
detection I have trained their mouths so
I they have a language model which is
sort of based on english language
documents what I do is I take the
purpose of Java documents that usually
are from the they would be from the
program that the user is writing take
that translate to spoken Java and train
so to continue training the speech
recognizer so that it's able to handle
things like saying import Java lying
system and both words can't come well so
that way it'll be starts good either way
whether most do you a commercial
recognizers can end Kendall in addition
to these kind of dictation language
models or something that is like
context-free grammar no not context-free
that's a statement yesterday in Britain
as a grammar fine but the bottom line is
you can express any BNF expressive oh
grandma that the recognize can take it
actually performs better so you are
talking about putting a lot of context
and back to the likes of recognize that
lexical analyzer why don't you push it
all the way to speech recognizer I see
what happened so the speech recognizer
can't handle recursive grammars and
there's no programming language in the
assistance that's not recursive but you
are going to say
no I am actually most of what you say in
the programming context even with a
short statement is highly recursive like
X get 6x itself is an expression get six
I can have like a statement instead of
just six i can say X gets call this
function and that usually looped back on
the same kind of expression you like
sweet emotion we still owe peace none
the lecture yet the lecture doesn't know
about much of this at all it's the
parser that has to know about all the
analysis so you can't really push it all
the way back into the speech recognizer
because the parser is really the one
that's the most powerful one to figure
out the context is but if it's a case I
mean you only need a left recursive
grandma and speech recons candles man
okay we'll talk about this later but it
they're generally limited to find state
machine grammars okay yeah modern
programming editors like eclipse or
Visual Studio they have these neat
features like you know pop up what's the
next method you want to things like that
so have you thought about how that
integrates into this kind of work
because I mean that makes typing much
faster already so does it speed up voice
my voice programming as well um so it
this particular way of doing things
where you're kind of it's a very model
editor you're editing a structure at a
time there's no opportunity for analysis
while you're talking so there's no way
to do the code assist which is the thing
that pops up the other things now one of
the reasons I think there's two reasons
for Kota says one of the reasons is
because you don't want to type out what
you already know you want and the other
reason is that you don't know what you
want and then you're kind of just
scrolling through and in the case where
you don't know what you want it's going
to be that there's no help right that's
something that could be done with the
next generation of this where you
actually start analyzing and you're
talking instead of analyzing fluid
structures
Doug it hard
so there's a lot of predictive like kind
of predictive parsing that would have to
go on and I try to do a slight side
project on that at one point you just
leave a little cookie behind couldn't I
say something like you know if X dot
intellisense you know plus 3 is less
than 10 and then after you've parsed it
you know that intelligence is a place
where I want you to go and pop up the
choices that's a fifth thing ok that's
just thing idea don't have to test that
see how that works any other questions
you know how they say that
grandma Lucia program okay yeah for that
I thought of all but i wonder
if if you enable programming my voice
you can actually enable you know
grandma's to programs enabling core
gaming by voice doesn't mean the
semantics of programming get it going to
get any easier or and then the language
is still hard to I mean even you know
it's still like you still have don't
know what you're doing I think there's a
whole brand of research on end user
programming and programming for Grandma
and programming specifically using
programming without computers like you
go to Intel Seattle lab who are working
on kind of stuff like context to wear
home and stuff just sort of non-textual
programming doesn't need to be on the
desktop
alright well thanks very much thank you
the shots does your grandma